ja und auch diese bilder hätte berlins
innensenator sicherlich gerne verhindert
sie erreichen uns aus den sozialen
netzwerken und auch hier sehen wir noch
mal die sich die demonstranten zum
reichstagsgebäude auf machen und
versuchen dieses zu stürmen einen
sicherheitsbereich durchbrechen und wenn
wir fahnenschwenken vor dem
reichstagsgebäude
wir sehen auch hier nochmal diesen
quoten misch wir sehen eine fahne aus
der türkei wir sehen die
reichskriegsflagge und wir sehen wie es
die menschen wirklich bis wenige meter
vor die tore des reichstags schafe sind
auf den treppen auf den stufen wen ihre
venen mit ihren fahnen und ja am ende
ist es nur noch diese gepanzerte
gesicherte glastür die sie davor schützt
da einzutreten und einige wenige beamte
mit schlagstock wieder in positionen
gehen ein stück weit auf verlorenem
posten kämpfen die man da sicherlich
auch nicht beneiden kann und möchte
wie sehen sie die bahn noch mit dem
schlagstock vorgehen um sich platz zu
schaffen und um die leute davon
abzuhalten am ende ist auch noch
tatsächlich ins deutsche parlament zu
schaffen und sie stehen nur wenige
polizisten gegenüber werden hier einen
kollegen aufzusetzen aber sich am ende
der muss man muss ja fast sagen
heldenhaft noch vor dieser tür gestellt
hat und auch am ende da nicht
zurückgewichen ist sondern es eben mit
bloßen händen ohne helm ohne schlag
stoff die leute probiert hat abzuhalten
also da gab es eine letzte
polizeieinheit die da wirklich die
stellung gehalten hat am auch das ist ja
wenn man solche bilder sieht ein
beruhigendes für eine beruhigende
erkenntnis dass deutsche beamte da die
stellung gehalten haben und eben
verhindert haben
das ja der mob da am ende ins deutsche
parlament rennen und stürmen kann
dennoch unglaubliche bilder lasst uns
einmal darüber sprechen wie das
reichstagsgebäude überhaupt gesichert
ist und es ist ja ein gebäude mitten im
herzen von berlin das natürlich immer
und zu jedem zeitpunkt unter
polizeibewachung steht desto ist hier
dass wir jetzt hier die beamten
verzweifelt gegen einen recht großen mob
von demonstranten an kanten dingen es
ist eine szene und bilder die es so nie
hätte geben dürfen und die wenn planung
zusammenhalt zusammenarbeit vor ort
besser funktioniert hätte koordination
besser funktioniert hätte so auch nie
passiert werden hier muss irgendetwas
schief gegangen sein irgendetwas mich
ganz schnell passiert sein dass die
beamten so überrascht wurden dass am
ende der einzelne polizisten isoliert
und alleine an den toren des deutschen
parlaments stehen und sich mit bloßen
händen und mit dem schlagstock einzig
glaube ich noch sein pfefferspray gegen
hunderte demonstranten wehren müssen